it really pains me to have to talk about
this today it really does but I'm really
worried about a faction of my audience
and and quite frankly I'm really worried
about the left and this is not concern
trolling I'm worried because of the
response to a video that I did yesterday
explaining some unfortunate realities
about Medicare for all I did a video
yesterday where I explained in no
uncertain terms were not getting
Medicare for all anytime soon now there
are lots of good progressive takes that
agree with that one example is
progressive economist Dean Baker's
recent comments about Medicare for all
he is a progressive I had him on the
show recently there was no question
about it I did the video in good faith I
said listen I'm for Medicare for all
I believe Medicare for all is the gold
standard I want Medicare for all
I'm not suggesting that we push lame
centrist policy because getting Medicare
for all will take much longer than some
people think I'm not suggesting that we
don't hold our candidates accountable to
the gold standard that is Medicare for
all but I explained some unfortunate
realities about Medicare for all with
the hope that once we all understand
these we can be stronger in our advocacy
for better policy as activists as media
people as voters people in the audience
the video I did is about 10 minutes long
and I expected that there would be some
comments and gave it you're kind of
being a defeatist here even though it's
not what I'm what I'm actually doing but
the reaction has been again it's just
from a piece of my audience a lot of
people understood what I was doing and
appreciated it three minutes after the
video was published remember the video
is ten minutes long
three minutes after the video was
published it had 50 dislikes it's only
been 3 minutes you couldn't possibly
have watched the 10 minute video even if
you had it on double time on YouTube in
the three minutes it took 50 people to
dislike the video and there are either
people who didn't watch the video at all
or people who done just watched it and
don't understand what I'm saying or
people making bad faith arguments but I
am very worried because if that is the
contingent that the success of our
movement depends on
we will lose and I hate to say that let
me give you some examples and again I'm
doing this because I want to win and I'm
worried that there are factions in our
movement that are totally misguided and
their reactions to people simply saying
hey guys we should be aware of this
stuff one example I'm not surprised
David is shilling against Medicare I
actually say in the video probably close
to a dozen times I am for Medicare for
all this is either an ignorant or a bad
faith comment another user responded
Bernie can establish a state of
emergency and sign it into law
Trump has set so many precedents listen
this is where the the the there is an
element of the left that is in a fantasy
world we are not going to get Medicare
for all established through a
presidential state of emergency I
understand that there's some
hypothetical world in which President
Bernie Sanders says our health care
situation is so bad that I'm declaring a
state of emergency and during that state
of emergency I am going to simply create
Medicare for all and then boom we will
have Medicare for all it's just
unrealistic okay it's not worth even
putting energy into that and responding
to what I'm talking about by saying
David Bernie we'll just declare a state
of emergency and create Medicare for all
it's not happening we are not going to
win if that's what we are hoping for or
waiting for another example this was a
very bad take and a bad faith argument
David well what was bad faith about it
they don't say this sounds like a Nancy
Pelosi speech please go back to being
more progressive people liked you more
that way I mean listen the show is
bigger than ever it's more than doubled
in the last year but that's not really
do you actually don't think that's the
issue that doesn't tell us whether I'm
right or wrong the idea that it's a bad
faith argument when I'm saying I'm for
Medicare for all we should still push
for Medicare for all we should demand
our candidates be for Medicare for all
that is what seems like bad faith to me
another comment okay
so David is basically advocating for
centrist policies so that we have a
chance for in the future no I literally
say in the video I am NOT suggesting
that we advocate for centrist policies I
say it in
the video so again either people aren't
listening or they're making bad faith
arguments and lastly now is the time to
unsubscribe from this channel do this to
be making a point no progressive should
ever be posting against Medicare for all
so again number one I say a dozen times
in the video I'm for Medicare for all
but more importantly that is the sort of
black-and-white thinking these these
bogus litmus tests that are not
connected to reality not only am I for
Medicare for all
I'm trying to figure out the right way
to get there one idea I had is it's more
likely to start with a state doing
Medicare for all that was one example
that I gave now fortunately I did get
some emails from people who took the
time to email me and say David I know
you're gonna get crap for this but
you're right and I think it's good that
you're doing it we need to be more armed
with facts so that we can better
advocate for what we want there were a
few YouTube comments that that seem to
understand what was going on one who
said these comments show people don't
listen to what he's saying yeah another
commenter who said the comments are
depressing watch the whole video he
supports Medicare for all he's talking
about strategy here he's talking about
reality he's right he's saying it
because people need to know the reality
we need realistic expectations and
knowledge about how the system works so
listen I'm not being defeatist I'm not
acting in bad faith I'm saying a Bernie
presidency doesn't get it for us for all
of the reasons that I cited yesterday
and more I want it I think it's the best
listen to what I'm saying it's not
impossible it's just way more work and
we need to know that going in and we
aren't going to succeed in any of this
if we imagine such delusional things as
Bernie will say we have an emergency and
put in Medicare for all it's not gonna
happen
it's not gonna happen and any time
wasted expecting that or suggesting that
is time that you were distracting from
doing the real work that needs to be
done prove me wrong I want to be wrong
okay this is one of those things where
if in three years we have Medicare for
all I will gladly show up and say you
know what I was skeptical but I was
wrong you all great activists prove me
wrong and we have Medicare
for all I hope that that happens but
it's not going to be closer to a reality
if the reaction is David you shouldn't
even allude to the fact that it might be
more difficult than some people are
making it out to be spend the time
advocating for a groundswell of
progressive candidates at all levels all
of whom want Medicare for all so that we
can take back the White House and the
Senate and governor's mansions and the
Supreme Court which will be crucial in
actually getting working Medicare for
all but if the reason if the reaction to
me being realistic is David you're a
shill you're a bad person for doing this
you shouldn't be saying this I'm now a
right-winger or a centrist or whatever
we will lose if we attack people who
agree with us on policy not because they
even disagree on one policy but because
they differently assess its path to
reality they will crush us they will
crush us we will lose if that's what we
do mark my words we will forget about
Medicare for all Trump will get
reelected we will not get the Senate it
is upsetting to see and I'll go even
further I've talked before about how our
system is set up to prevent people from
really activating what we really need
are mass rallies and urban centers we
need to consider strategic defaults to
[ __ ] the financial system mass work
call outs to [ __ ] industry serious
forms of protest but as I've said before
the system is the site designed so that
no one can afford to do that by keeping
wages stagnant keeping public transit
terrible in most places and the rest of
it we've talked about it before let's
work together because the reaction to
yesterday's video from this piece of my
audience is how we end up accomplishing
nothing and I don't want to accomplish
nothing I am NOT suggesting we give up
on anything should we fight for Medicare
for all yes we should should we always
start negotiations from the morally
correct position that we actually
believe in which is Medicare for all of
course but responding with kill the
messenger to I think some people are
missing the reality of how this becomes
the law how this becomes our
our status quo it's toxic and it will
destroy the left which I don't want to
see and I would actually argue that the
left has already been hurt by this
significantly on the positions we are
already with the majority of the country
every poll tells us on health care we
are with the majority on gun safety we
are with the majority one of the reasons
there are many reasons and many of them
are structural and repeat you know
gerrymandering and campaign finance I
get about one of the reasons why we have
not been more effective is this
infighting that exists when someone says
ham with you on everything except I
disagree about how easy you think it's
going to be and here's what we need to
know we're gonna lose we're gonna lose
and I don't want to lose tell me all the
ways that I'm wrong if you can actually
keep it issue based I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman leave a reply below I'm sure that
there will be more follow-up about this
upcoming